this is exactly what I needed to hear
because I am I can see myself spiral
even with you with this gift of having
the show that I'm on when I'm there and
it's everything that I've ever wanted
right it's everything right it's like
remember when she met me my career was I
had nothing
I really had I was like going on the
road these shitty comedy clubs but not
great thank you I mean great comedy club
and thank you so much for the [ __ ]
opportunity and for me to make money and
I'd really appreciate it and you guys
are all a list and great hey and I'm
very grateful for
we were happy here shitty last time he
plays Yeah right but um but even so I
would pray where I would like envision
please let me get back into you know the
graces of Hollywood and get a job right
and now that I'm on this job I sit there
and I'm just I'm sitting in this room my
dressing room and I just sit there and
as and then just in this misery you know
and and and I am I'm well aware of it
too I'm like huh this is everything you
ever wanted
right you prayed about it and now that
you're here you're in your miserable
what is that and I know exactly what I
need to do but just right now I haven't
been able to put one foot in front of
the other and go there I'm getting to
the point of the cliff where I have to
do it or I'm gonna [ __ ] relapse or
something even worse perhaps my whenever
I have found myself in that position and
I have and I hope to never do it again
but I think probably it will happen
again but whenever I've been successful
in breaking that cycle of anguish that
you're describing it has that I have to
do things even although I don't want to
do them so I have to you know in
Christian theology they say faith
without works is dead which i think is
actually quite an interesting way of
describing it the you believe what you
want but if you're a douchebag you're a
[ __ ]
douchebag you know so what you believe
and what you do have to be commiserate
they have they have to attach to each
other so if you say to you if you say I
am uncomfortable I am unhappy I have to
do all this thing but just saying that
doesn't mean [ __ ] unless you do
something right
so even although it's a little bit I
mean I I don't like to break the
traditions of you know the fellowship to
which I belong yeah but I will say this
that anytime that somebody walks into a
room like something like you walks into
a room of these meetings and says I've
had a hard time and I'm back there are
so I mean there's douchebags there let's
not be mistaken but that's not the
majority the overwhelming thrust of the
meeting will be we're glad you're back
it's good you're here here's what I did
when I felt like you yeah and and then
just do it you know and I think that for
people who are there's no embarrassment
in struggle I think there's an odd
there's an odd thing in society know
that that somehow struggle or mental
anguish or lack of success or is some
kind of failure
I believe on that Instagram evenings you
should like like like everything has to
be successful all the time you [ __ ]
nuts that's crazy how can everything be
grey all the time that's that's insane
yeah that doesn't that doesn't make any
sense
Wow and but people are like oh look at
my fabulous luxury yeah yeah if you say
like people who are who have been sober
a long time they say I'm great I feel
great I've never felt you know the need
to have a drink I'm like then I don't
very much you and I suffer from the same
thing all right
Wow yes you're right and you know what
dude it's like this man
yes underslept King in you stop looking
at me that way oh because he's never
seen me vulnerable before this morning
you're a racist look at me right now you
know I want to admit something to the
room John you know even though you're
never hearing
very good very good hair right it is a
father congratulations yeah yeah are you
high right now John seriously are you
high right now a little bit right yeah
yeah you look great oh hey you know what
dude
it doesn't interview with your life keep
doing your happy yeah happy but if
you're happy you're happy but look he
splits out of his [ __ ] mind yeah yeah
he thinks we're a [ __ ] fighter with a
kid all right
[Music]